I can date when my sister does you
kidding are you kidding me man what are
you kidding me you're kidding me
you gotta be kidding me are you kidding
me I mean are you kidding me are you
kidding me you gotta be kidding me yep
kidding me you gotta be kidding me
you're kidding me kidding me you're
kidding me right are you kidding me this
guy kidding me are you kidding me are
you kidding me are you kidding me are
you kidding me are you kidding me
kidding me kidding me what you're
getting me a while you've gotta be
kidding me
you gotta be kidding me geez you gotta
be kidding me you can oh you gotta be
kidding me
you gotta be kidding me he's got a kid
you gotta be kidding me gotta be kidding
me you gotta be kidding me
you've got to be kidding me you gotta be
kidding me right gotta be kidding me you
gotta be kidding me you gotta be kidding
me
you gotta be kidding me you gotta be
kidding me
you gotta be kidding me are you kidding
me are you kidding me come on you gotta
be kidding me
you gotta be kidding me I gotta be
kidding me you gotta be kidding oh you
got anything
yucky kidding are you kidding me you
kidding me
you're kidding me right are you kidding
me you're kidding me you're kidding me
are you kidding me
are you kidding me are you kidding me
are you kidding me right now
you frakking kidding me right now are
you [ __ ] kidding me
he's [ __ ] kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
you've got to be [ __ ] kidding me
honestly [ __ ] kidding me you gotta be
[ __ ] kidding me I've gotta be [ __ ]
kidding [ __ ] kidding me like do you
[ __ ] kidding me you [ __ ] kidding
me
you [ __ ] kidding me be [ __ ]
kidding me
Jesus
you blow up damn you damn you
you